Oh
so I'd like to talk about the topic of
curation just become a huge topic these
days as we try to manage the
overwhelming information flow is
competing for our attention we're all
suffering from intense information
bandwidth anxiety we're like a 56k modem
trying to download 10,000 hours of HD
video through that pipeline we simply
lack the biological hardware to actually
take in all of the information that's
competing for our attention today and so
curation has become the buzzword the
information diet of every single person
is now the craze how are you going to
curate your information diner you're
going to just create a filter bubble you
know because that's not curation
curation cannot just be filtering out
what you don't want curation needs to be
about creating the conditions in which
you can discover what you didn't know
you wanted when you can discover what
you didn't know would be useful curation
should be up all about serendipity which
is look for something find something
else and realize that what you found was
more conducive to your needs than what
you thought you were looking for so the
question today becomes can we design
algorithms can we design apps that can
that can leverage contextual computing
big data finding patterns create random
patterns so on and so forth to engineer
technologically mediated information
serendipity because that would really
upgrade the valuable meaningful the data
sets that we were able to absorb from
those information flows so that's how I
feel about the pivotal role of curation
nowaday nowadays and we need to figure
it out
you